Scaling and performance, two very widely
used buzzwords and at the same time
equally important concepts when we are
talking about systems, backends and
infrastructure and this is also a topic
which expands into a lot of territories
and a lot of domains. uh scaling and
performance has a very different
definition when we are talking about
browser systems or front ends and it has
a very different meaning when we are
discussing about infrastructure. uh but
in this video of course we are going to
cope it down to the concepts and the
things that are relevant in the context
of backend engineering and we will start
from the very beginning from the primary
question of what even we mean when we
talk about performance and we will build
up from there layer by layer and we'll
develop an intuition for how systems
behave for how systems behave under load
where bottlenecks actually hide and how
to think clearly when everything seems
to be falling apart when your system is
actually under load and I'm hoping by
the end of this video you will not just
learn about a few techniques about a few
scaling techniques you will understand
how to think about scaling and
performance in a way does not matter
whether we are talking out backends or
any other systems otherwise but your
knowledge should be applicable
universally in any system that you will
encounter in your future. So with that
let's start our discussion about
performance performance. So let's ask a
question first. What do we actually mean
when we say a system is fast? And by
talking in the context of our modern
systems, modern websites or modern web
apps, we can consider a system to be
fast. When let's say we have a website
or our web app and a user comes to our
web app and they do some kind of
interactivity. Let's say they click a
button on our web app and the moment
they click a button a series of events
start executing the browser that they
are interacting with let's say in this
case it is a Chrome browser the browser
sends a request across the internet to
our server the server which caters to
this particular front end or this
particular web app and our server
receives that request let's say is our
server And this is somewhere here,
right? This request comes to our server
and our server receives this particular
request. It processes it and maybe if
needed, it most likely interacts with
our database, right? To either store
some information or fetch some
information about the user or something
that the user needs any kind of
interaction with the database. And if
needed, it might also call some other
API. Let's say it needs to send an
email. So it needs to call the API of a
service called recent. Send an email to
a user and after doing all this has to
eventually send a response. Let's scroll
down a little bit. After doing all this
has to send a response and typically
it's a JSON response and that response
again travels back over the internet for
the internet and back to your browser.
Then your browser takes that JSON
response and by doing some kind of JSON
parsing or any kind of JavaScript
processing it shows it on the screen.
Let's say it renders a couple of cards.
Now there is some amount of time passed
between the user clicking the button and
the cards finally showing up on the
screen. this whole interaction and the
total time that it took for the user to
click the button to finally the
rendering of elements on the screen.
This whole thing that we can call as
latency, right? There's an first concept
that we are going to introduce and
latency is one of the most fundamental
concept when we are talking about
performance and when we are talking
about performance metrics metric in the
sense how to measure performance there
should be some kind of measurable unit
where we can define performance
mathematically or in some kind of
numbers instead of just talking about
figurative stuff like fast and all. So
latency is an important concept to
measure our performance and latency is
actually the the the the phenomenon that
users feel in a sense when someone says
that your application is slow. They are
talking about latency just so you know
and it does not matter whether they know
the word latency or not but they are
talking about latency when someone says
your app is fast or app is slow. But the
next thing that we should understand is
latency is not a single number. It is
not as straightforward as saying
something like 500 milliseconds. It is
not as simple as that. The latency it
varies from request to request. One
request might complete in let's say 50
seconds or no not 50 seconds 50
milliseconds. Another request might take
let's say something around 200
millconds. And why is there a difference
between the two? Because when we are
talking about real world, real world in
the sense when requests traveling
through internet, nothing is as
predictable as they are when you are
talking on whiteboards where everything
is measurable, where everything is
predictable. It's never as simple as
that. Maybe for this particular request,
it was able to hit some kind of cache
either some kind of CDN. CDN we'll talk
about what are CDNs or some kind of
in-memory cache like radius right it was
able to get a hit which means the result
of this particular request was already
present in a storage in some kind of
persistent storage which is much faster
than trying to fetch the result from a
traditional storage like database and a
storage which is much farther from the
user's location and this one had to
travel all the way back to our server
and it had to do a database query.
That's why it took around 200 millconds.
Or maybe this is not the case. The cache
is not the case. This request maybe the
reason was this request, the one which
took 50 mconds, it was able to get to
our server when our server was idle.
When our server was not really doing
anything and when this request hit our
server, it was already concurrently
processing like 50 other requests at the
same time. That's why this request took
200 millconds, right? It can be any of
these reasons since we are talking about
real world traffic. So if we try to do
something, let's say if we try to take
the average latency of all these
requests, let's say in this example, the
first one was 50 and the second one was
200 and the average would be something
like 125 milliseconds. If you think
about it, does this particular number,
the average latency of the requests
which is going to our server, does this
number say anything meaningful to you?
Now, averages are a very useful number,
a very useful statistics, when we are
talking about understanding systems in
other context. But when we are talking
about performance in particular,
averages can be very misleading and they
are in my opinion pretty much useless
when we are talking about performance
because the variations are very
important in this particular context. So
average is not that useful in expressing
the variations of the request latencies.
So let's consider a scenario. Let's say
you measured over a thousand requests
and the average latency that you got out
of them was around 100 milliseconds.
Okay. But in this particular number in
100 milliseconds that the average
latency number that you are able to
calculate there is a very misleading
outlier here because 99% of the request
they were able to complete under 50
mconds while the other 1% it took around
5 seconds. And this 1% this percentage
of users they describe they represent
real users in your system that are
having terrible user experience in your
web app. If you take the same math and
scale it up what happens? Let's say your
back end was able to serve 1 million
requests per day. Per day. Out of those
1 million requests, 10,000
10,000 requests, they had to wait for 5
seconds. Which means that after clicking
the button or after landing on your
screen, the user had to wait 5 seconds
or they had to see the loader for 5
seconds before any kind of data showed
up on their screen. Now, if you take
this math and calculate the average, the
average will tell you that your system
is performing very good. you have a few
hundred milliseconds of latency but you
will never understand the frustration.
You'll never get to realize your systems
limits when it comes to the 1% of users
who are having a very big a very
alarming amount of latency in their
systems. And this is the exact reason
when we are talking about performance
instead of talking about averages what
we actually talk about is percentiles.
And this is something that I have
mentioned in my previous videos which is
before understanding the mechanics the
hidden mechanics of a system before
understanding how a particular concept
works how to build that and everything
you have to understand the lingo of it
or the jarens of it so that you
understand different opinions in that
ecosystem different opinions that are
spread across a spectrum. uh that is the
same reason since we are talking about
performance you have to understand all
the lingo all the jarens that are used
when people are talking about measuring
performance when they are talking about
scaling and that's why percentile is a
very important terminology here so now
talking about percentile the 50th
percentile or also known as P50 when
people say the term P50 what they mean
is if your P50 latency is something like
400 milliseconds. It means that 50% of
your users experience 400 milliseconds
of latency. Same way the 90th percentile
also called as P90. It means that 10%
let's say if your P90 is around 900
millconds. It says that 10% of your
users experience 900 milliseconds of
latency. The same way another important
term is P99. Let's say if your P99 is 2
seconds, it means that 1% of your users
experience the latency of 2 seconds. In
other words also when we say P99
latency, it means 99% of your users get
a latency which is less than 2 seconds.
Which means it is for them the system is
faster as compared to the other 1% of
the users. But of course as compared to
that definition it is much more
intuitive to think in terms of if we are
talking about P99 latency it means that
if you minus that number from 100 which
is 1%. So 1% of your users experience 2
seconds of latency. Same way for P90 if
you minus 90 from 100 which is 10. So
10% of your users experience 900
millconds of latency. These three
numbers are very important. Every time
you are discussing latency, every time
you are discussing performance,
optimization, scaling, all these things,
these numbers will keep coming up P50,
P90 and P99. So if we represent this as
a graph something like this, right? It's
not a very good drawing, but let's say
this is your P9,
this is somewhere around P90, this is
somewhere around P50 and so on. So this
experience the maximum amount of latency
this a little bit less and this a little
bit le and other users experience a very
less amount of latency. So in practice
mostly backend engineers they focus
heavily on P99 and P95 latencies and the
reason for that is not just caring about
unhappy users. That is of course the
case. But the requests that end up here,
the requests that end up having the
maximum amount of latency, that's where
our most complex business logic is or
that's where our most complex database
queries are and that's where our most
complex service synchronization logic
is. For example, calling external
services, calling services, sending
emails, waiting for web hook calls,
etc., etc. So all these complex
operations are most probably happening
in the workflows of these latency charts
is P99 and P95. And [snorts] because of
that the users experiencing the P99 or
P95 latencies, they mostly represent our
most valuable customers. The customers
that are paying us a lot and the
customers whose workflows should matter
us more. For example, a user who is
making a payment, a user who is making a
purchase on your platform, that will
generate more complex database queries
that will generate more complex business
logic as compared to a user who just
browsing through your platform. That is
why caring about P99 and P95 latency is
important. Okay. Now, that's all about
latency that you should be aware of. We
still not have learned anything new,
learned any new scaling technique or
anything but eventually you'll be more
and more comfortable with the language
of performance with the all the
technical jargon of performance and
scaling. Another metric that we often
talk about when we talk about scaling is
throughput. Now latency tells us how
long an individual request takes from
origin to getting the response. But
throughput tells us how many requests
our system can handle in a given time
period. And this is typically measured
with something like requests per second
or requests per minute, right? The
throughput of our system. That's what we
call it. And the reason this is an
important metric and the reason that we
are talking about this is for your
system you can have a very impressive
amount of latency. For example, when
handling 10 requests per second, your
latency might be very less, something
like 150 mconds or something. But the
moment the request numbers per second go
up, something like,000 requests per
second, your latency suddenly increases
to 2 seconds from 150 milliseconds to 2
seconds. Right? And that is the reason
understanding throughput with latency is
also as important. It helps you answer
very practical very real world
questions. questions like can our system
let's say your system is a e-commerce
platform or you handle some kind of
learning management system or you sell
courses whatever system that you have
and you want to answer the question that
can our system handle the traffic the
traffic search or the traffic spike of
black Friday which happens very certain
right one big day just your traffic
spikes to hundreds thousands and
millions of requests So understanding
throughput with latency is very
important so that you can answer
questions like can our system handle the
black Friday rush. Similarly if our
systems can survive the load if we
suddenly started a email campaign we
started an email campaign or if we got
featured in a podcast or we got featured
in a very popular website or a blog. How
many concurrent users can we support?
How many requests per second can we
support before we'll start needing more
resources? All the answers of all these
questions can be answered only when you
understand throughput with latency. So
one thing is obviously clear latency and
throughput are connected to each other
but not in a way that makes intuitive
sense to us because as throughput
increases as the amount of throughput
increases the amount of latency also
starts increasing. It starts happening
very slowly at first but after a point
it starts increasing dramatically like
this right and this particular
relationship between throughput and
latency. This is a very interesting
concept in performance engineering and
of course we'll talk about this more in
the next sections of this video. Now let
us jump into more intuitive concepts
about performance and scaling. So let's
talk about a ice cream shop. Right?
There is an ice cream shop and there is
someone at the shop wearing a cap and
he's giving out ice creams. Right? So it
is a Sunday evening and you go to this
particular ice cream shop and when you
walk into the shop the shop is
completely empty and you go to the
counter, you ask for an ice cream, you
pay the bill and you instantly get an
ice cream. this ice cream gets
transferred to you and since you got the
ice cream you are very happy very happy.
Anyway, the point of this example was
you made a request and since there was
no one at the shop, your request was
responded instantly. So this is the
situation of low utilization with low
latency. Low utilization because the
shop was empty. The worker, the owner,
whoever was giving out the ice cream,
they were not really working very hard.
So low utilization of resources and also
low latency because you got your request
served instantly. So this situation was
very low latency. Now let's imagine it
is Tuesday lunchtime and you go into the
same shop. There is the worker hat
giving out ice creams. But this time you
are not alone here. This time there is a
huge rush. Since it is a weekday,
everyone wants to have an ice cream.
There is a huge rush and you are
somewhere in the line. This one in the
blue with a grumpy face. This is you. By
the way, you are standing here and
you're waiting for your request. So in
this particular case, even if this
worker, this ice cream shop worker, even
if he works exactly at the same speed,
preparing each ice cream in the same 2
minutes as before. For each ice cream,
it takes around 2 minutes to prepare. It
takes a long time for you because you
are waiting for others to get their ice
creams first. Now the concept that I
want to that I want you to pay attention
to is the workers execution rate. The
workers work rate has not reduced at
all. Previously they used to take 2
minutes to make a single ice cream and
right now they are also working at the
same pace at the same rate. But for you
the perceived weight time the actual
wait time has increased significantly
because you have to wait for the others
to get their ice creams. Now talking
about actual relevant stuff talking
about backend engineering your backend
systems your servers they act in the
exact same way when the utilization of
the resources of CPU memory whatever
when the utilization is low the request
comes and the response is sent back
almost immediately. The CPU grabs each
request, processes it, and returns the
response instantly. But as more number
of requests come, each request waits for
the request that is ahead of it to
complete until it gets its chance. And
they all start forming a queue- like
structure. So the higher the
utilization, the higher the utilization,
the longer the queue and also the longer
the wait time, the longer the each
request waits. Okay. Now talking about
all of this, the metric that I wanted to
come to was this one which is
utilization.
Utilization which in formal definition
in formal technical definition is the
percentage of your system the percentage
of your systems capacity that is
currently at use that is currently
running actively. So at 0% utilization
you'll say that your system is idle. It
is not doing anything. It is not making
use of any of its resources. And at 100%
of utilization, your system is maxed out
of course and it cannot do anything else
and it is at the brink of collapse. Now
an interesting relationship that I
wanted to show here is the relationship
between utilization and latency. Let's
say this is the utilization in our
x-axis and this is latency. Now the
counterintuitive relationship here is as
our utilization increases. This is the
relationship that we intuitively expect
from our system. The more utilization
that we have, the more latency will
experience a linear growth. But what
happens at 100% utilization of our
system? It does not stay linear anymore.
The more we are growing towards 100%
utilization starting from let's say 1 to
100 this is how the curve starts look
like it starts growing exponentially
instead of growing like this it starts
growing like this right this is a very
counterintuitive relationship between
latency and utilization and also very
important to wrap our head around the
concept of performance and scaling. This
is something that you should keep in
mind. We'll come back to this or we'll
connect our concepts to this eventually.
So again taking about a very irrelevant
example or analogy here to make it more
digestible. Let's say we have our
highway right? Let's say this is our
highway national highway. When we say
that our highway is at 50% capacity. So
let's say these are the cars. Let's I'll
make it as blue. These are our cars.
Okay. We can say that this is at 50%
capacity. There is enough space for each
car to overtake other cars and you know
go on its way. So around at 50% capacity
the traffic flows pretty smoothly in our
highway. The cars they can maintain
speed and everyone reaches their
destination in time in a very
predictable time. Now at 80% capacity
let's say we add more cars here or more
cars more. Now what happens? you will
start noticing some slowdowns, right?
Because the overtaking is not as
straightforward, at least not without
compromising your safety. Again, we
don't safety here. But the problem is
you cannot change your lanes as often
now because there are way too many cars
here and you have to think twice before
you change your lanes and you have to
strategize how to go from here to here
and all these different aspects that
come into play. Now let's say we raise
it to 90%. We add more cars here. Now
what happens? This traffic now becomes
very unpredictable. Sometimes it will
flow when the cars are perfectly aligned
with all the gaps. So each one can make
perfect turns and they can through. But
sometimes when we have very impatient
people on the road, the traffic will
jam, right? Because everyone wants to
pass through. No one wants to give way
to anyone. Now it has become very
predictable depending on the mood of the
people depending on a very unpredictable
out of control phenomenon of nature. Our
traffic can either pass through or it
can jam. Every time someone breaks,
every time someone changes lane, every
time someone starts merging, you'll see
a ripple effect when everyone behind
that car will start honking and they
cannot move anymore. Anyway, at 100%
capacity, let's say you have cars at
every spot now. There is no space to
move anymore. Now, at this point, no one
can move. Your whole pathway is blocked.
No one can move on our highway anymore.
So, that is a very irrelevant but very
intuitive understanding of utilization
and latency that we can think about to
make sense of our systems. Of course,
when we are talking about these abstract
analogies of highways, restaurants and
cafes, these very simplified examples,
it all makes sense. But the moment you
start putting all those concepts into
the context of computing, it starts
becoming a little unintuitive. Anyway,
you can do a onetoone mapping in this
case for the relationship between
utilization and latency. Now the whole
point of this analogy, the whole point
of the graph showing utilization and the
latency and the exponential growth
relationship between them. The point of
all of this is the realization that you
have to come to at some point in your
back end engineering career is you
cannot run your systems at 100%
utilization and also expect them to
perform well or at least perform in any
kind of capacity. you need some amount
of headroom, some amount of capacity
that is able to absorb the traffic or in
this case that is able to absorb the
request traffic. So usually in the wild
or in real world production systems
you'll see that most systems run at 60
to 80% utilization and reserving the 20%
for a buffer in case there are any
amount of traffic spikes. Another reason
to keep this buffer or keep this
headroom is because the property of
traffic is not very linear. It is not
like a metronome. Every second you'll
get this number of fixed amount of
requests. That never happens. The
varying nature of traffic is they come
in bursts. Right? This is also a term
you'll hear a lot when you're talking
about performance and scaling. Traffic
always comes in bursts. Which means that
at 1 minute a lot of requests will start
showing up in your server and another
minute there are zero requests. Then
after half an hour you'll get a thousand
other requests. So this is how the real
world traffic works at scale. So even if
your average traffic that is well below
the capacity which is like 50% or even
40%, these bursts when they happen they
can instantly do the spike and you can
easily go above 100%. And if you don't
have that additional buffer that
additional headroom for all these
traffic spikes your system will
obviously crash. So that is the reason
uh understanding utilization
understanding the exponential
relationship of latency with utilization
and the realization that you should
never and you can never run your systems
at 100% utilization. There should always
be some amount of headroom. There should
always be some amount of buffer for your
systems resources. Right? That is the
whole point of all this discussion at
least the first part of our discussion.
We have not even started with our
scaling and performance talks. I'm just
intuitively building the mental models
so that you can connect the dots on your
own instead of just mugging up all these
vertical scaling, horizontal scaling,
all these concepts that people just
throw at you whenever they are talking
about system design and performance.
Okay. Next, when you say your system is
slow, it means that something specific
in your system is causing the slowness.
Right? That's what we mean when you say
our system is slow. and finding that
particular something whichever is
causing this slowness that is called as
identifying the bottleneck. Bottleneck.
Let me a couple of circles here. This is
another important terminology another
jargon that you have to remember or at
least should be able to identify when it
shows up again. All right. Of course
this sounds obvious but in practice when
we are working with backend engineering
we often skip this particular step which
is finding that specific part of our
system which is causing the delay which
is causing the slowness also called as
bottleneck and we start just jumping
into solutions. We start jumping into
all the standard by the book practices
which are supposed to be implemented
whenever we encounter slowness in our
system. Whenever we encounter a system
lagging, we do things like uh we just go
ahead and add caching because we just
know from all the different resources
that every time you encounter any amount
of latency, every time you encounter
some kind of bottleneck, just go ahead
and add caching. That is the solution to
pretty much all kind of latency related
problems that we have always heard and
always learned. Or if our database seems
to be the problem, we what we do, we
let's say we are running Postgress
version 16, let's upgrade it to
Postgress version 18. Let's just upgrade
stuff. Let's just upgrade our packages.
Or if our server is seeming like it is
the bottleneck, then let's add more
servers. Right? In other words, we also
call it as horizontal scaling. And
sometimes we do get lucky. Sometimes all
this stuff, all these buy the book
solutions, they often help. But more
often we spend days or weeks
implementing solution to a problem that
we do not actually have. While the
actual bottleneck the actual specific
part of our system that completely
remains ignored and even after
implementing our solution our system
still remains slow because the reason
the system was slow there still out
there and still causing the slowness to
put this in perspective let's say we
have an API which is / products and it
is something let's say a patch call
which is we are calling this API with a
product ID path parameter and there's a
patch call to update a specific product
with some amount of information from our
front end. So let's say we have this API
and we note that this particular API is
appearing to be a little slow and the
first thing that comes to our mind and
in fact my mind is most likely the
database is the problem right because
well the database is always the problem
and what we do we go ahead and add
caching let's say we just add radius to
our stack and we add a caching function
in front of this API to speed up of was
now that I think about it caching an
update function does not make any sense.
So let's say this was not a patch call.
This was a get call, right? We are
fetching the details of a product. And
to make this API appear a little faster,
we go ahead and implement caching in our
service and add it in front of this API.
And we spend one week implementing
caching a system and adding it in front
of our database. And we go ahead and
deploy this change to our production
servers. And we observe and what we
observe the API is still slow. After
doing all this, after spending a week on
finding the solution and implementing
this solution, our API still appears to
be slow. So this time we think that
okay, let's get a little deep into the
problem. Instead of just assuming our
database was the problem, let's add
actual logs in our code. So we go ahead
and add timing measurements in our code.
When does the request arrive in our
system? When do we actually call the
database query? When do we call the
caching? etc etc etc. We add very
granular timing functions across our
codebase at least for this function. And
what do we discover? We discover that
this particular database query it only
takes around 10 milliseconds. And this
newly added radius cache. This takes 5
millconds. But what we additionally
discover is a logging function. a
logging function in our particular API
in our particular service function. The
function that we are measuring the
timing of this logging function writes
to a remote logging service something
like elastic search or whatever logging
service that we use which is not really
a problem. We often have to make use of
a remote logging service. But the
problem was this was happening
synchronously growously which means that
instead of doing it concurrently or
parallelly whatever you want to call in
the next video of this playlist we are
going to very extensively cover
concurrency and parallelism. So I'll not
get too deep into the technicalities of
the difference between the two. But we
can just on a very high level on a very
oversimplified level assume that instead
of doing it in a parallel way. What we
do we block this request. We make this
API call or whatever request or whatever
transmission format that we have to log
this in our remote logging service. Then
we resume our service. Then we resume
our API. And this whole thing takes
around 500 milliseconds. And in the end
what we realized the database was never
a problem because without actually
measuring what is causing the problem we
just went by the books and implemented
caching because every time we are having
problems with any kind of latency. We
have learned this that just go ahead and
add caching. That's why we were not able
to catch the real issue the catch the
actual culprit which was causing the
latency which was our logging service.
And in fact it was the synchronous
nature of our logging service which was
causing the actual latency. In the same
way there are a lot of cases when all
these unintuitive components of our
whole API workflow which is causing the
actual latency. But mostly we just blame
our database. We just blame our indexing
strategy. We just blame our caching
strategy. whatever uh the very obvious
ones instead of actually measuring each
part each component of our whole
workflow and finding out the root cause
that is the reason often when we
encounter some kind of latency in our
API we'll start investigating first into
our database query even though the
actual culprit might be something like a
JSON serialization step or an XML
serialization step or maybe the whole
workflow of the API is fast the code is
fast but the latency Laty is caused
because the response payload is huge and
the network transmission here is
actually causing the latency. So the
lesson in this part of the discussion is
without measuring you should never guess
which component which part of your
workflow is actually causing the latency
which is actually adding your
milliseconds number. So every time you
are talking about performance, never
guess, always measure, right?
Measurement is very important whenever
we are talking about performance and
scaling and optimization. And since we
are talking about measuring stuff,
another important concept that comes
here is profiling. You might have
already heard this which falls under a
little advanced category. But this is
something that you should also know of.
This is also uh something that you have
access to and that should be in your
arsenal whenever you are trying to debug
performance related stuff. So profiling
to explain it, it is the practice of
measuring where your application where
your system actually spends its time. So
these profilers they attach to your
running application and during runtime
during actual processing actual request
serving and what they do they start
recording a sample of that request
response data and monitoring exactly
what happens at every corner of your
system. Things like which functions are
executing when they started executing
when they gave a response and recording
all these different numbers from end to
end. Now the output of a profiler can be
very overwhelming because there are
thousands of functions and each
accounting for some fraction of total
time etc etc. So we have a tool called
flame graph a flame graph which makes
this whole output of the profiler a
little more digestible. So flame graphs
what they do they show you the call
stack over time. Call stack is basically
the function execution. So all the
variables that went to it the output etc
etc. So functions that take more time
they appear a little wider in the graph
so that you can pay a little more
attention to those functions and
functions that are called by other
functions they appear stacked on top.
Right? Another thing that you can take a
look at. So if you take a visual look
without reading into the output of the
profiler, you can make a guess about
where your application spends most time
on. But the first time you take a look
at your profiler output, you'll be
surprised because the bottleneck in most
real world applications, the bottleneck
is never where you expect. You will
assume that your bottleneck is your
complex business logic, right? The
CPUbound task is often the business
logic. But the actual time that your
application is spending on is
serializing the JSON. While you're
expecting your application to be
spending most time on database queries,
the actual culprit was you calling an
external API call in a loop, right? All
these things start showing up when you
start measuring your application end to
end. But the profiler is in my
experience not very good at IO bound
task. IOB bound tasks are basically all
these things which is database queries,
file handling, serialization or making
external API calls. All these different
kinds of tasks are called IObound tasks
which deals with input output and
waiting for the results of input output.
But the profilers are actually more
useful at measuring CPUbound tasks where
your application is actually using CPU
cycles where it is actually performing
some kind of computation. But most of
the time our backend applications uh
when we are talking about performance
problems are IO bound. It is always some
kind of input output problem whether it
is at the database level or external
service or or cues whatever mostly those
are the culprits whenever we are talking
about performance stuff unless you deal
with things like image processing or
machine learning related calculations
and all where there are metrics
manipulations and etc etc mostly in a
typical SAS applications it's always the
IO bound task that cause performance
related problems and CPU profilers they
are not very good at catching all these
IO bound task or at least measuring them
and that is the reason we have another
tool at our disposal which is called
distributed tracing and this falls under
the category of observability. Now
tracing what it means is it let's say a
request came into your system. So
following that particular request as it
flows through your system and it records
at what time it entered this particular
component at what time it started the
database query at what time it started
executing this particular function at
what time it left the function what time
it started making this particular
external API call all these things it
starts measuring. So after you have
spent setting up distributed tracing in
your API in your application, you will
see things like your particular request
which which was this one products/
product ID let's say in this case five.
This spent only two milliseconds in your
actual business code in your API logic
but it spent around 800 milliseconds at
your database query level. And now that
you have this particular data, you can
focus on your database query right. But
having these numbers at what level at
what component and at what element we
are spending the most time on to find
out this we have to implement a
distributed tracing in our application.
This is a very useful tool for measuring
different kinds of latencies in our API
very quickly. where it's due. Databases
are typically uh the bottlenecks in most
of the backend applications at least
when we are trying to optimize our
performance. Databases are one of the
first things that we take a look at and
there are good reasons for this because
databases typically they do the hard
work. They store the data whatever data
that we have they store it on disk
durably to persist that data so that
every time we boot our system that data
is available to us and same for
insertion updation deletion and
everything by also making sure there are
no crashes and there are no failures.
They also give us the guarantee of
consistency by handling things like
concurrent reads, concurrent writes,
locking a lot of advanced concepts and a
lot of advanced uh research go into
databases every day and they also
execute complex queries across millions
and billions of rows and all of this
does take some time. So we cannot really
blame databases directly for all our
performance problems. There are some
common uh lowhanging fruits when it
comes to the typical performance related
problem that we face related to our
databases. The first one which is a very
notorious problem which is n +1 query
problem. So in order to understand this,
let's say you are a front-end engineer
and you are on the client side working
on a react app and you are working on a
blog application and in order to show a
list of 20 blogs around 20 blogs in the
homepage you have to make a API call but
for each of those posts or each of those
blogs you also need to show the author's
name here and the author's name is not
available in the uh in the list API
where we are getting the list of all
these blogs details in there we do not
get the details for the author of a
particular post of a particular blog for
that what you do you make the first API
call where you fetch the whole list and
then in a loop for each of those blog
posts let's say items here you make
another API to fetch the author. So for
20 blogs you make 20 API calls here 20
author API calls and total how many API
calls you did which was 21 API calls for
showing this single page. Now this
pattern of fetching data, this pattern
of accessing data is called n +1 query
because you do the first query the first
query to get n items and then you do n
queries to fetch details about those n
it single piece of detail. Now imagine
for 20 you had to make around 21 API
calls. For 100 similarly you'll have to
make 10 and1 API calls. For 1,000 you'll
have to make, 101 API calls. On the
y-axis if you see the number of API
calls that you need to make and on the
x-axis you see the number of items that
you need to show then it grows linearly
with the number of items. So what is the
problem here? Now of course there is an
obvious problem the the number of items
that you need to show and the number of
network calls that we need to make
should not be related in a linear
relationship. So any engineer can u feel
that there is something wrong here. We
should not be making thousand requests
for showing thousand items. But even if
we ignore the obvious problem, the
second problem is each database query
has some amount of overhead because
there is a network involved which is
used to transmit the request and
response across starting from your
application server to your database
server back and forth. And for this
request transmission before this happens
there is also a TCP connection layer or
if you use connection pooling then u
will not have to do that. But assuming
uh you are getting a new connection for
this then there is also a TCP connection
um setup layer. There is the TCP
connection setup overhead. Even after
the request the query reaches your
database the database also has to parse
the query. it has to plan its execution.
It has to actually execute the query and
then it has to return the results back
to your application. So even if let's
say one query only takes 5 milliseconds
which is extremely fast but for showing
a,000 items and you're making thousand
requests which means a,000 queries which
will end up taking 5,000 millconds or 5
seconds. So for 5 seconds your users
users who are using your blog
application they are seeing a loader for
5 seconds straight is not a very good
user experience at least by the
standards of 2025. Now what is the
solution here? The solution is pretty
obvious. We don't uh even have to go
into the mechanics of it which is
fetching data in bulk. Right? Instead of
making thousand API calls for thousand
items, we should be able to fetch all
those thousand items in a single
request. So in our case instead of
making uh a thousand or a 100 API calls
a 100 different requests for fetching
the author details you collect all the
author ids in a single array or a single
list whatever data structure that you
use in your programming language and you
fetch all of those in a single request
in a single query. So now it will be one
query to fetch all the posts and another
query to fetch all the authors of those
posts. Two queries in total. It does not
matter whether you have to show 20 blog
post or you have to show 100 blog post
or you have to show thousand blog post.
You'll always need to make only two API
calls. If you don't see it in the
perspective of front end, if you see in
the perspective of your server, so far
we've been talking in the context of
your front end or your react app making
an API call to your server to fetch the
post to fetch the author information
etc. Even if you forget about this part
because server does not really store the
data in any way. The server uses the
database to store its data. So every
time you are fetching a list of posts,
the server is actually fetching those
list of posts from the database. In same
way, every time you are fetching the
author's information, the server is
fetching it from the database. The N +1
query problem is actually at our server
level, not at our front end level. So
traditionally one of the problems with
using OMS was people used to write uh
code like this. So in the so let's say
we have a uh function here fetch posts
and in this function what people uh used
to do was db dot select posts right
where user id is etc etc and fetch a
list of all the posts right this is an
array of posts then in a for loop for
post in posts fetch or select author
from users where user id equals to
author ID something like this. So in a
for loop they used to run and fetch the
information of all the others. Now this
was traditionally called the n +1 query
problem because when we are talking in
the context of database your server your
back end is actually the front end for
your database and the n plus1 query
problem traditionally happened at our
server level not at our front end level.
the front end uh example was just to uh
make it more intuitive. But this is
where the actual problem was. But in a
lot of modern OMS, for example, if you
take a look at Django, you can use
things like select related for fetching
all the data related to your foreign key
relationships or you can also do
prefetch related for doing things like
many relationship. Same way if you are
using Ruby in Rails then it has
something like includes and if you're
using a TypeScript type OM then it has
things like left join and select right
in pretty much every OM does not matter
you are using Prisma drizzle all of
these warms have primitives to bulk
fetch or to fetch data using joins right
if you are using SQL queries raw SQL
queries of course the solution is to use
join joints, left joints or inner joints
or whatever. But if you're purely
expressing your data fetching logic in
terms of your OM then there are
primitives available in your OM's uh
level to fetch all the related data
using foreign keys. And the solution was
this. Instead of fetching whatever data
that you need in a loop using your OM,
you should instruct your OM to fetch or
prefetch all the data that you need in
bulk before you run the query, right?
Which is much more efficient which only
runs around two queries or a single SQL
query instead of doing a,000 queries or
thousand items. Now the problem of N +1
query was very apparent using OMS is
because OMS give you this this way of
accessing data using your programming
languages types and constructs. So
something like this which is like posts
equals to await db dot select dot posts
where etc etc. Now after running this
statement you have an array of posts.
Now by intuition you'll do something
like for post in post await fetch author
information etc. Now it looks like
normal code to you. It looks like uh
your typescript code but since you are
using an OM and the OM has its own way
of fetching data which in turn uses raw
SQL queries behind the scenes but since
it looks very familiar a programming
language constructs we don't think about
how exactly the OM executes all these
statements behind the scenes that's why
in modern OM there is an option to u
print the actual SQL queries that it is
running behind the scenes. So that while
development you can debug whether this
is the SQL query pattern that you
actually want to execute or do you want
to make any modification or do you want
to write your own raw SQLs. So anyway
the problem of n +1 query is something
to be aware of and something uh to look
out for whenever you are using OMS and
databases. Always try to use joins and
your OM's bulk fetch constructs to avoid
the N plus problem. Now moving on the
second and the most relevant concept
when it comes to database and
performance is indexes. Indexes every
single engineer knows this. The most
common source of database performance
problems involves indexes or to be more
specific the lack of indexes the absence
of indexes. So uh people who are
familiar with indexes there is nothing
much to explain there. You have to
understand your uh data access patterns
through your application observability
framework and then accordingly you have
to add indexes to different different
tables so that the uh access is a little
faster. But uh just to give a brief
about what exactly are indexes whenever
we talk about databases and indexes and
the explanation for it. This is a very
common uh example that people come up
with which is the example of a library.
So imagine a library which has around a
million books in different different
shells, different different sections,
different different brooms, different
different floors. But there is no
catalog. There is no way to track down
which kind of books lives in which
floor, which section and which shelf. So
if a new customer comes or a new excited
reader comes to your library and they
ask for a book by a specific author,
right? Someone comes to your library and
says they want to explore all the books
of the author John Green. Now since you
as a librarian do not maintain any kind
of catalog whatsoever, you only have one
choice. Walk through the entire library
examining every single book and uh
collecting all of that and giving the
user a box which contains all the books
of geometry. And of course there is a
problem with that one. It takes a long
time probably uh 3 days until you're
done. And the second is if the user
comes the second time asking for the
same request asking for all the books of
John Green or a second user comes asking
for the same request again your 3-day
adventure starts you start collecting
all the books of John Green again since
uh after the user reads them or after
the user is done with all the books you
put it back in random order in the
shelves again. Anyway, so now that you
have some kind of a very irrelevant
intuition there, what we are trying to
explain with this library example is the
the activity of going through your whole
library, examining each book to make
sure that this is the book that you
want. This whole process is called a
sequential scan also called as full
table scan which means exactly what it
sounds like going through each row of a
table to find out if this is the row
that you want if this is the row that
you want and collecting them one by one
and returning the results to the user.
Of course since we are talking about
computing and databases it does not take
3 days to get the results. It usually
takes somewhere between 1,000
milliseconds or 2 seconds if it is a
very large table. But still from the
standards of our modern uh performance,
this is still slow. So what what is the
solution here? Going back to our library
example, if we as librarians, we
maintain a catalog. A catalog which is
organized by the author's name. Let's
say there are all the authors in the
alphabet A, B, C, N, and with the J. We
have John Green and with that we also
store the locations of all the books of
John Green and where are they exactly
stored in our library and once we have
that information we directly go to all
the places all the shelves all the
sections in our library and fetch all
the books and return it to our user
which takes around 2 to 3 minutes
depending on how big your library is. So
mapping it back to our database context
this is what an index is. It is
typically a data structure and usually
it is a B tree index. There are other
types of indexes called hash index and
all but for this particular use case
that we talked about we use the database
uses a B tree index a B tree data
structure and what is the property of
this particular data structure. It
maintains a sorted copy a sorted copy of
all the values of a column. Let's say uh
B indexed our posts table with the value
of author id. So starting from here like
1 2 3 4 and all. It will maintain this
list and the pointer to all the books.
Since author ID is a foreign key there.
So when you search by a particular
column let's say we want all the books
of author three. Then using this pointer
relationship, we can instantly get
access to all the books of that
particular author. Instead of your
database having to scan each and every
single row, it knows exactly which rows
it needs to fetch before. So of course
as compared to the full table scan or
the sequential scan, this is a much
faster operation. So the operation
depending on how many rows that you had
in the first place. For a million rows,
it takes around 4 seconds to find all
the books for that author. Then with an
index in place, it will take somewhere
like 40 milliseconds or 100 millcond
under 100 millconds, which is a huge
performance improvement. But with index,
there is another important fact that you
have to keep in mind, which is indexes
are not free. They are not a one-stop
solution to all your database
performance problems because indexes
have their own cost. The cost is cost.
First, each index it takes some amount
of space. Of course, if it wants to
store this sorted list with all the
pointers and all the information to
fetch all the rows etc etc. Then it has
to store that information somewhere. And
depending on how large your table is,
how many rows that your table has the
indexes the size of the indexed data
will also grow. So that is the cost
factor. The second one is the more
problematic one is that every index in
our indexed data, our indexed collection
here, it also has to be updated every
time you do an insert or update or a
delete row operation on your primary
table. the table of whose column you
have indexed. Every time you do an
insert, update or delete operation on
that table, your indexed data structure
also has to be updated. Since it has to
be in sync with all these operations so
that when you run a select query, it can
appropriately fetch the data without
being out of sync with the current state
of your table. So this is the second and
more problematic factor of using
indexes. So if to improve your
performance what you did for every
column of your table you went ahead and
created an index for that and every time
you do an insert update or delete
operation on that table all the indexed
data structure has to be updated and
you'll see huge latency numbers all your
right operations especially they will
slow down significantly because every
time they do a right operation they have
to update all these index data
structures one by one. So uh to find the
solution for this as I had already
explained in the database video instead
of defining the indexes of course uh at
the start of your migration when you're
creating new tables you can go ahead and
add one or two indexes for fields that
you know that are going to be part of
the query because by default the ID
field the primary key of a table is
already indexed by the database at least
that is the case for posgress so you do
not have to explicitly index the ID
field. You search by ID then it is going
to use the index to find that particular
row. But if it is any other column,
let's say we are talking about our books
table, then the ID column of the books
table is already indexed. But you have
to manually index the author ID field,
the authority column. And since we know
that the author ID is such a useful
column to search books by, we can go
ahead and add an index for author ID
while we are defining our table only uh
before we even write our APIs because it
is such a common use case searching all
the books of an author. But some of the
nonobvious use cases where we are not
really sure whether a particular column
is going to be part of many queries or
is going to be part of many joins
because in joins also uh indexes are
used. So if we are not very confident,
we are not very sure about that then we
should wait. We should actually uh
monitor our app. We should take a look
at our logs at our traces and after we
know for sure after we have the data
that these particular API endpoints are
being hit most frequently and using
distributed tracing we find out that
this particular database query is having
this amount of latency because of the
absence of uh an index on the ISBN
number field that is the reason we have
to index the ISBN number field ISBN
number column. So this is how in a real
production system we decide which
columns exactly we should index unless
they are very obvious like the authority
columns because indexes have a huge
overhead you should be very cautious and
not be very generous when you are
defining different indexes on your
table. Two other things that also come
here since we are talking about indexes
is uh composite index and also covering
index. It is important to understand the
difference between these two whenever we
are talking about database indexes. So
I'll just mention it in brief. Composite
index basically uh means that it covers
multiple columns column one column two.
So for example, if you frequently query
by both user ID and the column created
at created at then a composite index on
a structure like this user ID, comma
created at this will help you optimize
that particular query better than
creating indexes on these two
separately. Of course the order of
creating this index also matters. The
user ID comes first then comes the
created at. Because when you create a
composite index like this with the order
of user ID and created at, it anyway
helps you with a query where both user
ID and created at is used. But even if
both are not used, if even if you are
only querying by user ID, this index
still applies because this is the order
that you have applied it. But if you
only query by created at this index will
not be applied. So the ordering of
defining or creating this index matters.
So that's about composite index. Now
what is covering index? Let's say we
have a table called uh departments
departments and our uh internal sales
team frequently adds departments or
updates department deletes department
etc depending on the client
requirements. Now the department's table
has let's say a 100 different columns
but the only column that we need is the
name of the department which we show uh
in our front end in our client app in
our web app and also the ID of the
department. Since we only need these two
columns what we can do we can use a
covering index to index the name column.
And what happens when you use the
covering index is whenever you make a
query which only involves the name of
the department the database can serve
all the data that we need from the index
does not have to go back to the actual
table contents and fetch the data. All
the data will be available in the index
only and we can serve that from there.
Same way you can add multiple columns
but of course storing more data in the
index makes the size of the index even
bigger. You have to carefully analyze if
this is worth it or not. But the
question that you can ask in the end is
how do you know how do you actually know
uh which field to index at your database
level. Let's say using distributed
tracing you found out that this
particular query select dash from dash
join this these tables and with the
group I having whatever your complex
query this is this complex query. How do
you exactly know uh which column in all
this that you have to index? This is
very simple. A lot of databases offer
this very useful tool which is called
analyze or explain analyze. Whenever you
are running your query, if you add
explain analyze before the start of this
query, what happens? The database shows
you how exactly the database was able to
fetch all the data from uh which table
it started, what table it joined with,
what index it exactly used for fetching
that particular piece of data and you'll
find all the internal details of how the
whole query plan was executed from start
to end. And you can just take a look at
that query plan and you can find out uh
what are the columns for which we are
doing a sequential scan or a full table
scan. there are no indexes being used
and uh you can guess that if the rows of
this table are in thousands or millions
then this might be the cause of latency
and you can add an index here and even
after adding an index you can run the
same excellent analyze query the second
time and you can check whether our
database is able to use this particular
index or not if it is able to use that
particular index. So instead of showing
full table scan or instead of showing
sequential scan it will show you index
scan and your query should naturally
feel much faster. So by using this
measuring techniques using distributed
tracing to find out the exact database
query and then using explain analyze to
find the exact columns you can find out
the key of your performance problems in
your database. That's all about indexes
when we talk about databases. Next
overhead that comes is the cost of
connections. One of the realizations
that you'll have once you start scaling
your back end is the realization that
your database connections they are not
as cheap as you thought because when we
are working in local they are so cheap
that we never even have to think about
database connections or their relations
to uh performance overhead. But
[clears throat] when you start scaling
you'll see that database connections
they can get very expensive at scale. So
in order to understand that let's talk a
little bit about database connections.
Let's say we have our server here. So
our server and this is our database.
What exactly happens when your
application or your backend connects to
your database? How does this whole
connection work? To explain it simply,
it establishes what we call as a TCP
connection. Now TCP connection itself is
a uh three-way handshake process. You
send a SIM, there is an act, there is a
SIN or whatever which goes into the
network engineering domain. But just so
you know, we establish what we call as a
TCP connection and we uh use three-way
handshake for that TCP connection. After
it has established this TCP connection,
it performs any kind of authentication
if there are any necessary then it
negotiates the encryption algorithms
like private key, public key and all
that infrastructure. Then it sets up a
session state for the data access. Then
the database actually allocates some
amount of memory for this connection.
Some megabytes or MBs for starting out.
So this is all the things that happen
each time your server establishes a new
connection with your database. All these
things happen one by one and of course
all these things take time and
resources. So the point that we are
trying to make here is if your
application if your back end establishes
a new connection for every single
database operation and instantly closes
it once it is done with that particular
single operation then this whole cost of
setting up a database connection you'll
keep paying it repeatedly again and
again and here you are going to pay with
the cost of latency latency of setting
up a connection every time you get a new
HTTP request, every time you have to
make a new database query. The second
thing is the databases limit because the
database also has a limit for number of
connections that you can establish with
it. A typical Postgress database has a
limit on let's say a fewund connections
500 or 600 depending on how large of a
memory how large of a CPU that you have
configured for the database. But talking
in general you have let's say around 500
or 400 to 500 connections of limit. So
if your application has a traffic spike
or if it's a busy day some kind of sale
happening then your back end can easily
exhaust all the database connections
since it is going to uh deal with all
these different HTTP requests
concurrently dealing with 500 or
thousands or u 10 thousands of requests
in a second or minute it will easily
exhaust your databases connection limit
and your database will crash. So in
order to prevent this particular problem
of exhausting the connection limit and
the first one is the paying the cost
factor every time we want to make a new
database query creating a new database
connection. To avoid those two issues
what people have come up with is the
concept of connection pooling. A very
important concept when we are talking
about performance and scaling. Now
connection pooling solves both of these
problems. the problem of having to
establish a new connection with our
database every time we want to uh make a
new database and the second thing is the
the danger the potential of exhausting
our database connection limit and how
does it help us. So instead of
establishing a new connection with our
database every time we want to make a
new query what we do we interact with a
middleman which we call as the database
pool. This is our server. This is our
database. And instead of uh directly
interacting with our database, we
interact with the pool. And what does
this pool do? These connection pools,
they in turn send our request to the
database in a more optimized because
what a pool does, it maintains a set of
connections. Instead of repeatedly
opening a new connection and closing it,
it maintains a set of open connections,
set of idle connections or whatever we
call in the terminology of pools.
Basically a set of connections it has
readym made for us. So when our server
when our back end needs to interact with
our database what we do our server asks
for a connection asks to borrow a single
connection from our pool and it takes
that connection and using that
connection it makes the database query
which is the result after it is done it
gives the connection back to the pool.
So after that instead of closing the
connection after we are done with our
query the pool keeps the connection open
depending on your configuration uh it
depends uh how long the pool will keep
the connection open but it will keep the
connection open for some time that you
can assume so that the next time we want
to make a new database query it will
reuse the same connection instead of
creating a new connection to our
database. By using this pool
architecture we got rid of those two
problems. Even when we are talking about
uh database pooling, there are two types
of pooling patterns. One is using
internal what is say and the second one
is external pooling. Internal pooling
just means uh usually these days all the
modern database drivers. They provide
pooling at your applications level. they
the database driver itself maintains a
pool of connections and you interact
with that pool to uh make database
queries and give it back and all. It is
called internal because it is specific
to your server and since in our modern
uh web application structure we don't
have a single server when we want to
scale we add multiple servers. So for
each of these servers since we are using
internal pooling they will have a pool
of connections. Now the problem with
this is the way we configure our uh
scaling the scaling of our server. This
is called horizontal scaling. When you
add more instances of our server when
our traffic spikes, right? So the one
scenario one problematic scenario here
is let's say our traffic spikes at this
point and uh our Kubernetes autoscaling
infrastructure what it did it added two
more instances. So each server maintains
a pool of let's say uh 150 connections
at a time and since we added three
instances that is 150 150 150 which is
around 450 connection atoms that you can
assume or the 450 is the maximum amount
of connection that we will be able to
push to. Now the problem is our database
can only handle 300 connections and now
the moment the traffic spikes again and
we push to let's say 400 connections
between all these three instances of our
back end of our server our database is
going to crash because we exhausted the
pool limit and that is the reason we
have external poolers. So for Postgress
a very popular external pooler is called
PG bouncer. Take a look at PG bouncer. G
bouncer a very lightweight connection
pooler for posgress. It is also open
source. You can take a look at this. But
the whole idea of PG bouncer is let's
say we explore the same scenario again.
We have a traffic spike and our
Kubernetes autoscaler added two more
instances of servers. But this time
instead of each server having its own
internal pool of connections, what
happens? We configure an external PG
bouncer pooler which maintains a pool of
let's say 250 or 300 connections and all
the instances of our server they
interact with this pooler. Since this is
an external pooler, all of them have
access to this using some kind of
networking. And this in turn deals with
our database. And now we will not be
exhausting our database limit because
since this single pool interacts with
all the instances of our server, there
will never be a scenario where we will
exhaust our connection pool without
realizing because a spike in our
traffic. So that is the difference
between internal pooling and external
pooling. When we are scaling, when we go
to production, we usually prefer
configuring an external pooler,
something like PG bouncer as compared to
internal pooling, especially if we are
aware of our uh traffic spike patterns
and with that we have covered some of
the important performance related
concerns when we are talking about
databases. The first one was N plus1
query problem. The second one was the
indexing strategy, what to do, what not
to do. And the third one was the
overhead of creating, establishing and
destroying connections again and again
and the importance of using pooling for
performance. So by this point you have
already optimized your queries, you have
added all the appropriate indexes and
you have configured your connection
pool. But still your database is the
bottleneck. Still you are seeing latency
at your database level. Now at this
point the obvious next step should be
caching. Of course we have discussed a
lot about caching in the caching video
in this playlist. So we are not going to
go too deep into the mechanics of
caching. But we'll still have to discuss
caching since we are talking about
performance and scaling. We cannot do
that without mentioning caching since
that is such an integral part of our
performance or our systems performance.
The idea of caching is beautifully
simple which is store the results of any
expensive operation. Let's say in our
case the expensive operation is the
database layer. So whatever expensive
operation whatever complex queries that
we are running here we take the result
of this and we store it in radius or any
kind of caching solution that you use.
So the next time a request comes instead
of going through all these complex
queries we do a detour here and we check
if our caching layer already has the
result of this particular complex query
or not. If it has then we directly
return that response instead of going
through this path which let's say takes
around 500 milliseconds or let's say 800
millconds. But if we return the same
response from our caching layer it takes
around 50 mconds. So with just one move
we were able to reduce the perceived
latency from 800 mconds to 50 mconds.
That's the part about caching that all
of us all the engineers know this the
very obvious use case of caching. But
while we are discussing about caching,
one of the most common disadvantages of
using caching or one of the most
problematic situation while using
caching is cache invalidation. There is
a famous code around here which is there
are only two difficult problems in
programming. One is naming things,
naming your variables, naming your
functions, naming your classes. And the
second one is cache invalidation. And
that is not an exaggeration. If you have
personally implemented multi-layer
caching in your system, cache
invalidation is a very difficult problem
because of the fact that it touches upon
so many layers starting from your
servers to CDNs, your client's browsers
and whatever comes between that things
like reverse proxy and all these things
when the actual data for example in our
case when the result of this particular
complex query which we were running
through SQL on top of our database. This
data, this underlying data actually
changes. We cannot serve the same old
cached data anymore. We have to
invalidate that cache somehow and
keeping this cache data in sync with our
original data which lives in our
database. That is the difficult problem
that we are talking about. So in order
to deal with cache invalidation, we have
primarily two techniques that we
regularly use. The first one is
timebased expiration and the second one
is event based invalidation. First one
is time based invalidation and second
one is event based invalidation. Time
based invalidation is pretty
straightforward. We decide beforehand
that we want to keep this cache valid
for this amount of time. Let's say for 5
minutes or 10 minutes. After this amount
of time, this cache should expire and
the next time a new request comes, we
should consult with the original source
of data instead of taking the cash data.
That's what we mean by time based
invalidation. But of course the problem
here with time based invalidation is
figuring out the optimal amount of time
for our expiration for our automatic
expiration which depends on our users
access patterns the frequency with which
our API is hit and that again differs
from endpoint to endpoint and from
service to service. So we have to take
into account a lot of these things
before deciding on the optimal amount of
time for automatic cache invalidation.
The second technique that we have is
event based invalidation. This one is
much more simpler. This basically means
that every time we make a change to our
original data, for example, let's say we
were caching the result of a user's
profile. So every time an update
operation happens on top of this user's
profile every time the user updates
their name their email or any kind of
preference in that same endpoint in that
same handler code after updating the
user's data in our database we go ahead
and we invalidate this cache or we just
delete this cache. So the next time we
hit the get endpoint for getting our
user profile, we'll check if there is a
cache entry for this user's profile. And
since we have already deleted this cache
entry since there was an update
operation on top of user's profile, we
do not find a cached entry. And because
of that, we consult our original source
which is a database and we fetch the
user's details from the database and
return it in the response. And this way
we do not have to guess. We do not have
to predict the optimal amount of time
for automatic invalidation and we know
exactly at what point we need to
invalidate the cache. But another small
problem with this is at your at code
level at every instance where you are
updating your user's profile data you
have to remember to also invalidate your
cache since there is no automatic
expiry. If you forget even one instance
where you are not invalidating the cache
then there is a risk of showing stale
data to your user. So both of these
methods have their pros and cons. That's
about the problem of cache invalidation.
Now talking about caching where does
your cache actually live? What is the
location of your cache? Now here there
are two options. The first one is called
local caching and the second one is
distributed caching. Local caching
basically means that instead of storing
your cache in any external service, you
create a data structure, something like
a dictionary or a map and you cache
whatever values that you want to cache
inside that map and you keep that in
your own server's memory. But the
problem with that is if you have 10
instances of your server, each server
will hold a map which will maintain its
own local cache. Now there are 10
different server instances and for each
server there is a copy of it own local
cache. Now you have the problem of cache
inconsistency between all these 10
servers. When we say distributed
caching, what do we mean by using an
external service something like radius
or memcached whatever external service
that you typically use? There is also
the modern option which is called Valky.
The advantage of using a distributed
caching service or an external caching
services. Now even if you have 10
instances of your server, all of them
are communicating with the same caching
server, right? So you don't have the
problem of cache inconsistency anymore.
But the con here is getting the value of
cache now requires a network round. The
distance between this and this can cause
some amount of latency here. When it is
in memory caching, it is almost instant.
We are talking about 2 to 3 milliseconds
of latency depending on how large your
payload is and what kind of
serialization that you use. But when
there is a network roundtrip involved,
even if it is an internal network, we
are still talking about 50 mconds of
latency at least. So what many systems
use, they use what we call as tiered
caching, a small local cache for the
hottest data. And by hottest data we
mean the data that is of course this
will differ depending on what kind of
caching algorithm that you're using
whether you are taking into account the
last used value or the most frequently
used value as a but the hottest data is
in the sense the data that is in demand
the most that is kept in the local cache
and as an upstream server to that we
have our distributed cache something
like radius. So when some function, some
request needs some kind of data, it
first goes to the local cache, checks if
the local cache has it or not, and then
it goes to the global cache or the
external cache. And depending on the
request configuration, depending on our
algorithms configuration, after it
fetches the cached item from our global
cache, it can decide whether to store
that value in our local cache or not
depending on how hot that data is.
Another important thing when talking
about caching is the caching patterns.
Primarily we use three kinds of
patterns. Cash aside, right through then
right behind. Caching pattern basically
means that at what point do we actually
go ahead and cache the data? How do we
decide which pattern that we should use?
And to answer that question over the
time people have come up with different
different techniques and depending on
what kind of access pattern that your
application has, what kind of access
pattern that your users have and what
kind of access pattern that that
particular endpoint has, you will end up
using either of these three or more
caching patterns. Now the first one
which is the cash aside pattern. This is
the mostly used pattern. This is the
pattern that we implement even if we
don't know that this is the name of that
pattern which is the cash aside pattern
which basically means that let's say we
have our database here there is a
complex query that need to run for our
endpoint which is / users/ user ids in
this case two. So the request comes
first it checks our caching layer let's
say this is our caching layer. First, it
checks if the result of this user's
profile is inside our cache or not. If
it is found inside the cache, then it is
returned as a response immediately. If
it does not find it in the cache, then
it consults our database. It runs this
complex query, finds the result, saves
it in the cache, and then finally
returns the response. Similarly, when
some kind of update operation happens
[clears throat] on this user, our
application code explicitly goes ahead
and deletes that particular cache entry
or invalidates that particular cache
entry so that the next time a new
request comes for the get endpoint of
our users, it does not find a cache
entry so that it goes to the database
and finds fresh data so that we never
end up serving stale data to our users.
This whole pattern is called the cache
aside pattern or the lazy loading
pattern is the mostly used pattern in
backend engineering and also the most
intuitive pattern. Same when we say
write to it means that instead of
invalidating or deleting the entry in
our cache every time a user's
information is updated in our database
what happens every time a write
operation is completed on our database
what we do instead of just updating the
database and invalidating our cache this
pattern updates both the cache and the
database at the same time. So instead of
invalidating it just updates the cache
entry and that's why we call it write
through cache. The advantage of this is
obviously there is never a cache miss.
We are always going to find a cache
entry for our users profile details. But
the disadvantage for this is our write
operation takes a few milliseconds more
because we need to write to our database
and to our caching layer at the same
time before we can return a successful
response. And finally we have write
behind. This takes a clever approach
since in the earlier approach there was
the problem of latency because we had to
write both to our database layer and our
caching layer before we returned a
successful response. What happens in the
write behind pattern is whenever there
is an update operation in this case
let's say we are updating the name of
the user. So instead of updating both
the database and our caching layer, what
we do? We update our caching layer.
Since updating any kind of operation on
our caching layer is extremely fast, we
finish this operation and return a
successful response and asynchronously
update the value in our database. Now
with this pattern, we can mitigate the
risk of latency of updating both the
database and the caching layer. But the
problem with this is if for some reason
our database operation fails. Now our
caching layer and our database layer are
in inconsistent state. So those are a
few caching patterns that you should be
aware of while thinking about scaling
and performance. One last topic that we
should cover under the caching section
is the number which we call as cash hit
rate. This particular metric basically
says that what percentage of your
requests are successfully able to get
the information that they want from our
caching layer and how many of them are
not able to get that information and
they have to consult the original
source. If you say you have 90% cache it
rate, it means that 90% of your requests
are able to successfully get a response
from the caching layer and only 10% of
the requests have to get to the original
source which is our database since they
did not find the response that they were
looking for from the caching layer. Of
course, 90% is a very good cach rate for
a system. If you have very low cash
rate, if you have cash rate of something
like 20%. It means that even though you
have implemented a caching layer, but
your caching algorithm or your caching
pattern, there is an issue somewhere
that you need to find and fix. So what
are the factors that actually affect our
cached ratio? Some of the important ones
are first is your TTL, the automatic
expiry property that we set on our cash
entries. If you have a very large TTL
then that will in turn affect your cash
at leio because since a lot of items are
living in your cash for a long time
there is a good chance that they will
get a hit sometime in the future. But
with a large TTL there is also the risk
of stailness. If you set a very large
TTL let's say something like 7 days then
that completely defeats the purpose of
setting a TTL in the first place. Now
you have to actively fight the problem
of stailness. The second factor for your
cache it rate is the cache size. This
matters because the larger your memory
is the larger your caches size is the
more amount of data that it can hold and
the more amount of hit that it can take
right it is pretty obvious. Third is
your data access patterns. If you don't
understand which endpoints of your
application of your back end are
frequently accessed and at what time
these endpoints are frequently accessed
basically if you don't understand your
users behavior then your caching
algorithm your caching patterns your
caching strategy is not going to work
and you will not see a very good cash
hit ratio something like 80% or 70%.
Since you don't understand your users
and the cash hit ratio directly depends
on how deeply you understand the
behavior of your platform at least the
behavior of your users or their access
patterns. So that is another factor that
affects your cachid ratio and that's all
about caching. Now moving on, let's talk
a little bit about scaling directly
instead of all the factors that affect
scaling. Let's talk directly about
scaling a little bit. Since this is a
video about scaling and performance
literally we have to talk about the the
obvious parts the standard textbook
answers of scaling which is vertical
scaling and horizontal scaling. Now to
reach there the primary question that
leads us there is your application runs
on top of servers and as your traffic
grows as your user base grows those
servers and the resources that these
servers have they start becoming
insufficient and over the time you'll
need more and more and more capacity. So
how do you actually get it? To answer
this particular question, how do you get
more and more capacity? That's where we
have come up with these two broad
categories of scaling. So there are two
fundamental approaches of scaling. The
first one is vertical scaling. Second
one is horizontal scaling. Now vertical
scaling, this is also called as scaling
up. So you can imagine it as scaling up
in the sense increasing the height of
your server or making your server more
and more powerful. So that is one
intuitive way of imagining vertical
scaling which basically means that you
take your old server and in order to
make that a little more powerful you
replace that with a bigger server with a
little more powerful server literally.
And how do you do that? using a couple
of obvious hardware upgrades. First,
CPU. You can go ahead and add more and
more cores 2 4 8 etc. Second, memory,
which means your random access memory
and your primary memory, whatever you
call it, the fastest kind of memory. You
go ahead and add more and more memory to
it. So, initially, if it was 2 GB, you
make it 4 GB, then 8 GB, then 16, then
28, 32, whatever your server's needs
are. Third, you can also scale it up by
storage. If previously you had 30 GB of
storage, you make it 300 GB, then 1 DB
and so on. Fourth is the network card.
Of course, in storage, you can also go
ahead with SSDs, NVM SSDs, etc., which
offer a much faster access time with
modern technologies. And lastly, the
network card, the modern network cards
which offer 10 Gbps and all which will
offer you more capability to handle
internet traffic. Now the beauty of
vertical scaling or just adding more and
more power to your server is its
simplicity and the intuitiveness. Your
architecture, your systems architecture,
your your backends architecture, it does
not change at all. You don't have to
think about statelessness and all this
different code level stuff. Just go
ahead and upgrade your machine. As
simple as that. Your code does not
change. And a server with twice as many
CPUs as compared to before can handle
roughly twice as many requests. Right?
That's just simple math. Same for the
memory. A server with twice as much RAM
can cache in local twice as much data.
Right? everything you can just go ahead
and multiply with two. Your capacity is
literally multiplied by two depending on
how you are upgrading. If you are if you
had 16 GB of RAM and you made it 32GB,
now we can say your caching capacity has
been increased the multiple of two. And
for this simplicity and the
intuitiveness for a lot of applications,
vertical scaling makes a lot of sense.
And even if you take a look at it
economically, a server with twice as
much power typically costs less than two
servers of half of its size. And on top
of that, you also avoid the operational
overhead of managing multiple machines
with things like security, backup and
maintenance, configuring load balancers
and handling distributed state. There is
a lot of complexity when we are going to
talk about horizontal scaling or adding
more instances to your server. Now the
question is if vertical scaling is so
simple and it is so intuitive why is not
every company doing this? Why is not
every single engineer is doing it? And
the answer to that is vertical scaling
has hard limits. What kind of limits?
limits because no matter how much money
that you spend there is always going to
be a ceiling on how powerful a machine
can be and that ceiling is at the
hardware level because cloud providers
even if you take a look at GCP or
digital ocean whatever that you're using
they do offer very large instances
depending on your use case but at some
point you are going to reach the biggest
machine that they offer with let's say
32 cores or whatever the biggest machine
of Aless is and what do you do after
that if you need more capacity if you're
getting more user traffic if you're
getting more requirements to scale even
after that what do you do you cannot
scale vertically any further there is a
hard limit and you have already hit that
limit the second thing the first thing
is the hard limit the second thing is
the single point of failure which means
that if one very powerful server with 32
cores with 96 GB of RAM you have a very
powerful a beast of a machine but if
your server crashes for some reason
maybe it is a a dependency related issue
or some kind of issue servers crash
every day for a lot of reasons so let's
say this vertical server that you have
which is very powerful in itself but it
crashes for some reason and for that
whole window let's say your application
crashed for 2 hours when you are not
available. For those 2 hours, your
application, your platform is completely
unavailable. Your service is completely
unavailable. Of course, you can mitigate
this particular risk of unavailability
with things like standby servers or
automatic failovers. But still the fact
remains that one single server does not
matter how powerful, it creates this
risk of single point of failure. And the
last thing is no geoic
distribution which means that even
though your server has 32 cores 96 GB of
RAM but let's say your server resides in
USA and 40% of your user base is in
India what happens then 40% of your user
base they experience increased amount of
latency as compared to the 60% of your
user base. Even though this is one of
the major chunks of your user base,
since you have a single server which is
a vertical server, even though a very
powerful server, you cannot do anything
to decrease this latency that your users
regularly experience. Because of all
these things, even though vertical
scaling makes a lot of sense, vertical
scaling is very intuitive and it is very
simple. does not require any kind of
programming complexity, core level
complexity or management maintenance
level complexity. There are major
disadvantages here. That's why the
majority of the tech community or
companies have moved towards the other
solution of scaling which is horizontal
scaling which takes the completely
different approach. Instead of taking
one machine and adding more and more and
more powerful to that machine, making it
scale vertically, what horizontal
scaling does, instead of instead of
adding more and more powerful servers by
replacing the existing servers, we just
add more instances, more counts of that
same server horizontally, which means
all these servers work together to cater
to our growing user traffic. Instead of
one powerful machine serving all your
user base, you have multiple mediumsized
medium powerful machine serving your
whole user base. There are also some
very clear theoretical advantages here.
And I say theoretical for a reason.
We'll come back to this. One of the
theoretical advantage, the mathematical
advantage is if one server can take,000
requests per second, then if you have
five servers, then you have the
capability to take 5,000 requests per
second. one of the clear wins, one of
the clear advantages of horizontal
scaling. Same way if suddenly you have a
big campaign coming, then the only thing
that you have to do is add more number
of servers or more number of instances.
If you need more, just keep adding, keep
adding, keep adding. You can just keep
scaling horizontally as much as
possible. You never ever hit a hard
limit because there is no limit on how
many servers that you can configure to
work together to serve your user base or
your user traffic. The other advantage
is the redundancy which means that if
one of your server fails then it has no
effect on your user traffic. Your
services do not stop because whatever
user traffic that you have at that
moment they get equally distributed
among all the other service all the
other instances that are available. Even
though one of your instance go down
there are other instances to take its
place to serve to your traffic. Third
thing which was one of the major
disadvantage of vertical scaling was
again geographic distribution. Since you
are just adding more and more servers to
your stack horizontally, what you can
do, you can add all these instances from
different different geographic locations
and they can together form a network and
using some technology something like a
load balancer which we'll talk about in
a little bit which will take a request
and depending on the user's location it
will pass that request to the nearest
server. And because of this setup, you
can have minimum amount of latency in
serving your users. That is another
clear win for horizontal scaling. Now
coming to the disadvantages. Of course,
there cannot be only pros and pros of
horizontal scaling. If that was the
case, then we wouldn't have even
mentioned the existence of vertical
scaling, right? Everyone would have just
gone and implemented horizontal scaling.
Now the disadvantages of horizontal
scaling lies in its complexity. The same
complexity that vertical scaling
completely avoids. One of the primary
question the one of the first questions
that you have the moment you start
adding one more instance of your server
or two more instant or 10 more instance
is how do you distribute the requests
among all your servers. What you need?
You need some kind of a load balancer.
Now that is introduction of a completely
new component, a completely new element
in your stack, in your network stack, in
your infrastructure stack. And the
addition of a new element means that
addition of more complexity in your
infrastructure. So by using a load
balancer, you can distribute the traffic
among all your servers. Now that you
have a load balancer, you also need to
choose what kind of load balancing
algorithm that you want to go with,
right? Another decision that you have to
make, another choice that you have to
make. Then the next question is how do
you keep all your servers in sync? For
example, if the user updates, the user
goes ahead and updates its name in
server one, then how does the server two
know that there was an update for the
user in server one? Next question is
what happens when the network the
network that keeps all these servers
connected that enables all these servers
to communicate with each other. What
happens when this network fails? How do
these servers communicate with each
other? And in turn, what if they start
making conflicting decisions? Since this
communication medium failed, they will
start making decisions which might be
redundant with the other server or it
might be conflicting with the other
server. or what happens when you have
let's say three server instances and one
of the server instances dies. How do you
know that this particular server is not
available anymore and how do you pick
that particular incident and how do you
decide at what point we need to route
the request to these two servers and
stop routing the request to this server
and how do you decide at what point we
need to start routing the request back
to this server the moment it starts
coming online. That is another question
that you might ask. Of course, all these
questions that I mentioned here, all of
them have answers. We have already
figured out the answers to all these
questions. But all these answers are
complex and they involve some amount of
tradeoff because we are talking about
distributed computing here. We are
talking about distributed systems and
distributed systems they do not really
get rid of problems for us. they just
transform one set of problem to a
completely different set of problems by
making a certain amount of trade-off and
sometimes these new set of problems are
more favorable to us as compared to the
original set of problems and that's why
original set of problems and sometimes
the original set of problems are more
solvable as compared to the new set of
problems and using this comparison of
which set of problems that you want to
deal with which set of questions that
you want to answer.